Science is everywhere. In the beauty of nature, in laughter between friends, buildings
Which we build, and the societies that we form. She constantly wonders ... ask, why things
They are what they are. How can we make things better? What we are in the grand scheme
For the universe? It extends from the depths of space to the device that we are watching
On this video, for now.
During the Age of Enlightenment, the scientific revolution came with ideas on account (differentiation and integration), atomic theory,
And gravity to our world. The Industrial Revolution, saw the importance of technology and the development of manufacturing industries
Including the first cars. In the digital age, scientists urged
On the formation of the Internet as we know it, as a means of exchanging research and ideas. Today,
Progress in medicine and agriculture saved more lives than lost in all
Wars in history.
But despite these achievements, science and society are often at odds. Scientific discoveries
Like a spherical earth, that our planet revolves around the sun, or that diseases spread
Through the germs that were every time ideas rejected by the community. So much so that Giordano
Bruno Cad burned to suggest that Earth was not the center of the universe,
Galileo even turned to house arrest to support this theory. Today we see
Reject scientific evidence of vaccination - leading to the return of preventable diseases such as measles
After being eliminated in 2000;
Or the rejection of scientific evidence for climate change, despite the great consensus between the views of scientists.
As Carl Sagan said, "We live in a wonderful society based on science and technology,
Which hardly anyone knows anything about science and technology. "
But when we look at history, we see that science may ignore the collapse
Of communities. Ancient Greece was a time of great knowledge about place and time ideas
And during the later Roman period most of the empire adopted these ideas. However,
The Romans were satisfied with the learning of the Greeks, little innovation or exploration
New ideas about science and knowledge occurred during this era. With turning
Governments and values, focus on reason, science and retreat away and Rome in the end
Fell in the Dark Ages.
Today, despite the many voices supporting logic and reason, this war continued on science.
In the UK, investment in publicly funded research fell to less than 0.5% of GDP - for
The lowest level was in two decades. This year, the United States cut at least $ 300 million
Of NASA's Earth Science Budget - which happens just to include climate science. Not
Only does this mean that the current climate studies will be ignored, but will not useful data
Until they are collected in the future, all to serve ideological agendas.
but why? To save banks in America costs more money than the entire NASA 50 years
Operating Budget - A budget that evokes imagination and visions for the future of our world
Universe. And the military budget? One month spending is equivalent to the entire NASA
the annual budget. Here in our home of Canada, the war on science
Is in full effect under Stephen Harper's conservative government. Libraries Our Science
Dedicated to health, environment and fisheries the oceans are being shut down. Laws which
Once to ensure the protection has been devoured endangered species, with
80% of Canadian freshwater fish species 71 are currently at risk of extinction. And not only
Canadian Prime Minister Stephen Harper dismissed the role of national science adviser, but some
2,500 federal scientists lost their jobs. In a recent study, 90% of government scientists
I felt they could not talk freely about their research and nearly 25% of those who said they were
The government had to change their research for non-scientific reasons.
We said that the remaining funds are oriented towards science which has a clear business
The resulting. Which at first glance may seem fair - research that is not 'a waste of money'
as it were. But, when Einstein constructed the theory of relativity, he knew that
Would lead to the development of GPS, nuclear power, or original TV? this is
Industries are billions, but the focus on commercial production is short-sighted, as science has learned
It is often slow, sophisticated, and an iterative process.
Science is much more than just a collection of knowledge and applications; it's a way of thinking.
A way to uncover secrets in the world, we see it is beauty - where we can look at all
The facts to make informed decisions, instead of relying on prejudices and prejudices'.
No knowledge does not choose a political party - they simply adhere to the evidence. But only
Good policy is also supported before science, science is supported by funding and advocacy
From our Governments. So when you head to the polls to vote, wherever you are, remember
That vote for science, is a vote of knowledge and progress based on reality. Look at your
Policies of Parties to science, take a stand.
If you believe in a successful science integration letter in our communities, please
Share this video - on Facebook, on Twitter, through email and in person - to remind
The importance of science.
Subscribe to get more science weekly videos.